John Holt is writing in asking about
becoming a public speaker wants to be a
speaker wants find places to speak and
fail as a beginner but in places that
won't ruin his credibility in the future
when he's awesome so what advice you
have about becoming a speaker and
failing at the start and finding places
to get some experience so you can
overcome those early adversity yeah you
kind of set out like gum in terms of the
question is all about practice you know
was another know some families go for
thanks gary player who said kind of the
more practice the luckier i am the more
you practice the better speak he will be
and i just think it's a gift but it's a
gift that can be taught and learned and
it's an area where you know we talk
about an internship before it's in there
well i'll start you wanted to get into
it go into an area actually which is
sometimes the most difficult area people
one should know you sometimes you will
feel that it's easier to present to
complete strangers than people who know
you but actually if you work and start
presentations with people who know you
then it could be like at a new community
group or you go back to your school if
you've got a job where you're a startup
or decoder you go back to talk to the
computer science um kind of high school
kids and do a presentation about why
should they be excited about what
computer science and coding and that's a
great way and then you can kind of go
along to the teachers to teach and say
can have that dean walker differently
what correctly but after though when
you've done a presentation then it's
about those magical open questions those
friends of yours like what could have
done better what could have done
differently you know didn't walk
messages till we kind of resume and and
i'm so kind of just always ask for
feedback feedback is absolutely the food
of improvement so that's what I'm
test-driving actually say don't worry
about failure there is no failure it's
just um practice I totally green I would
also start a YouTube channel get used to
speaking in front of a camera and having
people see your opinions and maybe it's
a little less intimidating than speaking
in front of an audience at the start I
get a lot of me
most of my speaking gigs through my
youtube channel people see me talking
and they want to hire me to speak at
different events and you talk about the
question talked about places to speak
word ruinous credibility in the future I
don't think there's that many places you
really have to worry about ruin your
credibility you know the first place I
spoke out was the YMCA and three people
showed up at my free event uh you know
not not the biggest start but does it
look bad on my résumé that I've started
the YMCA you know I don't think there's
that many places that really would be a
knock against you that's what you
started so just start to all the Stevens
wants reach out to your network places
that you work before teachers clubs that
you're a part of I just offer to do a
speech to get some practice and and also
get on youtube film those speeches do
your own sessions just one on one with
the camera and the more practice you get
like Steven said the better you're gonna
get it speaking the other things further
you know back to your business your
dream following your dreams Trump picks
on me your passion of them because
people when they're listening to you
will fill that kind of infectious
contagious energy that passion and that
will travel across and it will be
absolutely propelling so trying you know
if ever through a great motivational
speaker because your passion about that
you believe you've got loads of
experience relevant but your heart is
totally aligned to the passion and
that's why you're such a compelling
speaker and I kind of think you have to
be something that you really care about
and that always helps to give you that
energy and and the motivation for people
to this